so you saw the Nintendo LeBeau trailer
you saw the crazy fishing rod and piano
and backpack and all sorts of
contraptions you can build using your
Nintendo switch and some cardboard and
now you have questions namely how is a
Nintendo lab Oh any different from this
and how does it work together with this
well lucky for you we got a chance to
play it and we learned a lot every lab
Oh creation starts with several sheets
of cardboard perforated so that you can
pop out the necessary pieces from there
it's a matter of bending and linking
together the cutouts to build the toy
con whether it's an RC car or a box
meant to resemble the ocean yes Nintendo
really did take joint con and turn it
into toy con cute I guess but building
is also where my first concern comes in
I honestly felt like I was gonna break
every piece as I freed it from the
cardboard and bent the corners as
instructed so parents if you're buying
this for your kids make sure you build
it with them when the toy con comes
together you're left with a cardboard
peripheral that you feel pretty good
about having built yourself from there
each individual creation uses either the
Joye cons motion sensor or built in
camera to control the game yeah that was
night vision you just saw the joy con
has a legit camera inside of it
it even has predator heat vision the
level of physical interactivity with
each game is fascinating whether you're
inserting keys into a house to play
minigames or throttling the handlebars
in a motorbike race in fact I honestly
felt safer wielding the completed toik
on with the switch inserted then I did
putting the thing together in the first
place
how much time you'll actually spend with
the games is questionable but there's a
novelty here that brings to mind other
Nintendo benchmarks like Wii Sports
absolutely and in fact that's why the
lab o is made of simple cardboard you're
being encouraged to build whatever you
want from scratch we can't show it here
but label includes a feature called the
toy con garage where you can program
different joy con functions to control
games that means using the bike
handlebars to steer the RC car or even
building a completely original creation
so it's really not all that
different from this but when you combine
it with this it shows some real
versatility for the switch the joy
Khan's work in conjunction with a are
stickers this is actually how the piano
plays different notes other contraptions
like the robot backpack include weights
and pulleys too so pros and cons the
games are fun it's fully customizable
and the cardboard is well it's just
cardboard so way those for yourself and
maybe you'll have some fun building a
toy con whether it's with friends family
or by yourself
[Music]